that's our purpose here that's our
purpose i always wanted to know the
human purpose here
is to enrich the world someone's gonna
come along one day and they're gonna say
whatever it is what are we doing right
now the form of a rich in the world
and the way now now we have this you
know how many millions and hundreds of
million people know that he does this
[Music]
now
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to another episode
of hotbox and i'm evan britton
and i'm mike tyson and mike we've got a
really fascinating guest today
fascinating i like that word we've got
the man
justin wren in the house welcome my
brother
man thank you so much how you doing i'm
doing good thank you so much mike this
is a pretty surreal
for me to be here with you guys uh my
guy matthew right here
has watched every episode of the podcast
all 53 or so that you guys have released
i love it he absolutely loves it
after your first episode he said i've
got to be on the show
and so i'm so grateful that you guys are
having me on hey man he's a great hype
man to know that you got to get on hot
boxing yeah
so get the word out there mount well
justin i mean you're a professional mma
fighter but really
i mean you're so much more than that
you're an incredible humanitarian
right now um the most timely issue
that you're really the tip of the spear
on
is this anti-bullying movement and
standing with raiden
yeah who's a young man in high school
actually he's 12. he's a big boy though
yeah
he's 12 years old um
maybe before we jump into that why don't
you tell us a little bit about
your journey to starting fight for the
forgotten
sure and um yeah let's just start there
man
okay first just so grateful for both of
you guys having me on
uh thanks this is awesome thank you uh
fighting
for me was something i found after
getting
relentlessly bullied growing up i think
a lot of martial artists mma fighters
grew up being bullied not being the
bully
and so found martial arts through being
bullied and so
that was my story uh at 13 years old i'd
already gone through five years of being
relentlessly bullied sitting at the
lunch table by myself
not being welcome at other tables um
getting pelt in the back of the head
with
chocolate milk spit wads or other pieces
of food or
fist as kids walked by i remember
getting
uh i don't know beat up in the locker
room i was in eighth grade seventh grade
and uh was in the football locker room
just sitting there
got hit in the back of the head with a
football helmet didn't even see it
coming just got blindsided by it cheap
shot
uh had my my clothes from the
locker room while i'm in the showers um
you know all my clothes thrown out into
the
the the auditorium or the the gym
the volleyball girls and uh you know i'm
12 years old heavyset kid and all my
clothes are in
with the uh the girls volleyball team
and i don't have anything to cover up
with
and so uh then other times publicly
ridiculed i'll give you one
story mike real quick but uh my middle
school crush
wanted to catch her attention um biggest
crush i'd ever had
and so i uh i found out she was having a
birthday party
i got the invitation to it it was a
costume contest the winner was going to
get a prize
and so on it said the prize was a dr
pepper gumball machine
so dallas fort worth dr pepper is a big
thing and
i found out other people were going as
batman superman all these different
things
um or or characters i probably should
have gone to thor
you know being a viking looking guy uh
but i found out she loved transformers
and her favorite transformer was optimus
prime
so i decided i would go as dr optimus
pepper to her her birthday party so her
dad worked at dr pepper
she loved transformers there was a big
factory there
yeah down down near dallas fort worth
that's where her dad worked
and that's why the prize was a dr pepper
gumball machine because he worked there
so anyways from head to toe i lived in a
little country town crowley texas
and uh my mom with some duct tape and me
with some cardboard boxes of dp dr
pepper
we made myself into dr optimus pepper
head to toe
24 pack on the head 12 packs on the arm
chest plate a shield and a sword
went to the party my mom said man she's
gonna love this
get to our party her grandmother mimi
opened the door
and he goes oh my gosh jennifer's gonna
love this she was surprised but like
jennifer's gonna love this
walk in the rumors at school were true i
get to just push the button
i didn't have to pay for it and the dr
pepper pops out they had this
in there in their living room i go the
backyard open the door
and i met by all my peers and i hit with
a couple flashes of light
and my eyes adjust i hear the sound of
laughter and i look out not one
of my classmates are dressed up it was
just me
and then i hear my middle school crush
crush me saying i can't believe you
thought you were good enough
to come to my party next to her tyler
said you're worthless
and next to her justin warren or justin
a guy
said um you should just kill yourself
really and so
not it was just a big setup not one
other kid dressed up just me
just so that they could publicly
ridicule me shame me and
that's when i started the biggest battle
of my life which was against depression
um in suicidal ideation you know at 13
years old
just like with raiden right now being 12
years old you believe the things people
say about you
you don't have that resilience built up
in you yet and the effects of bullying
can last a lifetime
unless you have some big life
transformation thing happen
a coach come into your life and mentor
you tell you can be great
believe in you and so yeah at 13 years
old i started that biggest battle
of my life probably a few weeks after
that maybe a couple months after that
i found uh mma i was at a uh it's called
traders village it was like a flea
market
in dallas fort worth and i found a used
vhs tape store
and when i was there i found mma it was
ufc
not one one was missing but i think it
was like ufc two through nine or two
through eleven
and i spent all my allowance on that
because when i found it i looked at
these guys
and my first initial thought was these
guys don't get bullied
that was my first thought and then
turned it over i saw boxing
versus wrestling versus kickboxing
versus jiu jitsu versus sumo versus all
these things
and so i bought it all went home with it
i'd hide it from my parents my parents
were real conservative
um and uh but i just i just fed on it i
loved
i love that these guys probably don't
get bullied but i fell in love truly in
love with the chess match of it
combining all the different sports
putting into one this is kind of funny
i don't really share this but uh when my
dad found the used vhs tapes under my
bed
he thought it was a stack of porn but it
was just mma
um and yeah so that's kind of how you're
an mma
so yeah but that's that's how it all
started how i found mma
was was through being bullied and then
figuring out these guys don't get
bullied
um and so that's whenever i started my
martial arts journey and found wrestling
and fighting and
started pursuing it wow then when you
find out this is interesting because i
understood that too
nobody [ __ ] with these guys but then
when you realize in life
these guys are school everybody's scared
of who are
emotionally psychologically they're um
they're very kind
they're very loving and they want to
love everybody and they're easy to take
advantage of psychologically mentally
financially and stuff
so they get bullied from a different
perspective then
yeah that's a good point yeah yeah well
and then from there
at 15 started wrestling uh i had two
olympic gold medalists as my high school
coaches
that taught me to visualize yeah kenny
monday
yeah kenny monday and kindle cross i
know if you know kenny monday but he's
been my coach for
more than 15 years now since i was 15 to
32.
wow man uh first uh african-american to
win the the wrestling
uh olympic gold medalist or being an
olympic gold medalist and
incredible he's been such a guiding
light in my life
a coach a mentor and he's like that for
so many guys now he coaches mma
um and he taught me to believe in myself
because when i first stepped on the
wrestling mats i was completely timid
because i had been bullied for since i
was at least eight and i'm 15.
so i would i would i would telegraph
everything i was gonna do
i would show uh what i was gonna do
before i did it so the guys who know how
to defend it because they've wrestled
their whole life or even if they had a
year on me
they knew what i was gonna do before i
did it and then those guys just started
teaching
not just muscle memory but but but
really confidence
having confidence in my moves and then
finally just kind of clicked one day
and i became a state champion then
all-american the national champion
and then i went to the olympic training
center after high school went straight
to the
otc for greco-roman wrestling um started
fighting
uh was the youngest guy on the ultimate
fighter tv show
no [ __ ] yeah youngest guy yeah well for
the heavyweights 21 years old amazing
19 was when i started fighting
professionally mma and
a lot of wrestlers are a little older
whenever they get into it but i jumped
right into it
and uh yeah it's kind of funny this was
before it was all regulated
so it's kind of from the old school guys
a little bit even though i'm only 32
right now
i was at a fight i was supposed to coach
my opponent or sorry my the guy was
cornering had a staph infection
and uh so i was the one chosen to go to
the press release or the press
conference and let him know he wasn't
going to show up for weigh-ins
because he was in the hospital on ivs
because his his staff infection was so
bad on his his
uh thigh mic this comes from wrestling
jiu jitsu a lot not as much in boxing
the staph infections
but um he literally had this huge divot
in his thigh
yeah um in the this died from that stuff
yeah this guy
all the way down into his femur bone his
staff got into his femur
um so he couldn't fight the opponent
started talking trash saying that he
ended up in the hospital one night early
that he was going to send him there the
next night anyways
the promoter came up to me said hey you
want a chance to shut this guy up and
i was like man i'm a wrestler i'm not a
fighter i don't know how to do this
i just came here to be his wrestling
coach and the guy said hey if you
if you stand with him you're going to
get knocked out this guy's a kickboxer
don't stand with him put him on his back
and beat him there and he's talking to
me like i'm actually taking the fight
i'm like man i came here to coach
he's like hey i'll give you the
opportunity to to fight tomorrow night
oh that guy told me no he's the real
promoter this guy
right yeah he's got you in a fight yeah
a little
little little podunk show in in oklahoma
oh my god
next night it was about a minute and a
half into the fight and
uh put him on his back and then then
finished him with ground and pound
next fight was kind of the same thing an
opponent or a guy was supposed to coach
had a cold
the third fight i was in iowa and i was
actually in the stands
and i was 19 years old drinking a beer
with a fake id
and uh the guy the opponent my opponent
that night
went into the cage and the promoter said
his opponent that weighed in yesterday
didn't even show up on the night of the
fight and so they were looking for
someone that weighed over 206 pounds
and if there's someone in in the stands
that wants to fight just raise your hand
so my my friend looks at me goes what
are you doing i'm wearing like a
button-down shirt
jeans uh nice shoes and i kind of raised
my hand
and he's like what are you doing so i
literally had to borrow someone else's
fight shorts
i had to borrow uh someone else's jock
and cup
and i had to use a boil and bite
mouthpiece put it in a coffee cup
or coffee pot oh my god boil it down and
so those are my first three fights
wow dude listen um you know how
fortunate you are
aren't you yes you know most guys they
don't finish
like you normally they they they don't
they have normally that that's the last
three fights they have and they're
talking really funny for the rest of
their life
yeah you're very fortunate man i'm
grateful i'm grateful now that
um so you asked about fight for the
forgotten and what i've learned is that
fighting against people for competition
that's one thing but it's a completely
different thing fulfilling
um for me at least and that's why it's
my life mission and life passion to
fight for people
so getting into that um mike i got to go
after
five years of fighting professionally um
i mean i ended up being a depressed
drunk drug addict hooked on oxy um
went missing for eight weeks fighting
didn't fulfill me like i thought it
would that childhood dream became a
reality
turned into a nightmare um because i
lost all my money
became an addict um and winner win or
lose i had an excuse to
to use um and so i went missing for
eight weeks
like literally like my parents didn't
know i was best friend didn't know where
i was
a family girlfriend no one knew where i
was and i was
hitchhiking from drug house to drug
house in colorado
hook man so deep into oxycontin
and my best friend left me a voicemail
saying i can't believe you missed my
wedding
i can't believe my best man didn't show
up and so i was that hooked on
on the opioids um and almost took my
life
from that and then from there that kind
of scared me sober went back to my fight
team
they voted me off it was 34-1
and that was like some of the best
fighters in the world shane carwin
brennan chob
nate marcourt dwayne bang lugwig rashad
evans
some big name guys uh voted me off the
fight team
and so that was kind of rock bottom for
me uh that nightmare was even being
taken away from me
which was just my identity was being a
fighter and so then i started
volunteering at different things and
by happenstance ended up living 11
months later after being
a bit sober and big life change
ended up in the congo living in the rain
forest
with the pygmy people the
hunter-gatherers
and got adopted in as family with them
um
and uh wait a minute dude how did you
just end up there
yeah i think how did you how did the
fountain
happen with you in the pygmy
okay well i do want to talk about
staying with raiden but i got to share
this then
yeah yeah we got plenty of time dude
yeah go tell us
i mean this is fascinating so how did
you
i ended up in the congo meet the pygmies
get adopted into the family
yeah it was wild how did you
get to the congo what was it that did
you buy a plane ticket and said i'm
going to the congo or
like how did that come about i did that
but it was
something absolutely wild that that got
me
up to that point what was it i've been
i've been a little timid to share it out
there
publicly because i know it sounds wild
it's uh say it chris
if you can say it so so uh 11 months
mike you probably did visualization
right a lot of visualization in my life
every day of your life every day okay
yesterday today this morning
before i come here okay well during the
day here i would do it yeah
well so before i'd go wrestle uh we had
sports psychologists at the olympic
training center
that would take you through
visualization drills like see what color
singlet you're wearing your
your wrestling uniform is it red or is
it blue the two two colors that they
allow at the olympic level
see yourself shaking hands with your
opponent you walking out on the mat
what's the sounds what's the smells
you know what's what's your game plan
how are you setting that up
um how what's your first tie up and your
first setup
to your first takedown okay he got the
takedown how do you reverse it
and you see this in your mind a hundred
times before you ever go do it or more
yeah well this was unlike anything i'd
visualized
because i wasn't coached into it all of
a sudden it just happened
um and i was 11 months into this kind of
life change i had stopped fighting and i
thought i was going to stop fighting for
a year
well this was 11 months in and so i
started looking for a fight again
um and man all i did was i said this
quick simple
sort of prayer where i said god what do
you want me to do with my life that's
all i said
and man i had a movie in my mind
that i didn't try to conjure up i didn't
try to
fabricate all of a sudden i was taken to
the forest
and i was walking down this footpath and
then all of a sudden i heard
drumming and i keep walking down this
footpath in the forest and i clear like
thickets out of the way
and then i hear singing a very distinct
kind of almost yodeling type singing
and then i come into this clearing and
uh and i i meet a guy
um or i see him and i see his ribs kind
of poking out and he's coughing and i
knew that he's sick
and my eyes just adjust i see these twig
and leaf huts
and then i just was flooded with this
knowledge of who these people were that
they were
hungry and thirsty and poor and sick
oppressed and i knew that i knew that
they're enslaved that they called
someone else
master and then i felt that they felt
forgotten that's all i knew was
forgotten i grabbed this piece of paper
and i write forgotten on the top of it
and hungry poor sick oppressed thirsty
enslaved
and then and before i ever wrote that i
just came out of that vision just
crying unlike i've ever cried in my life
for these people that i don't know
i don't know who they are where they are
but i left a little
like that much of of tears you can't
call that a puddle but
i mean that's a pretty big size of tears
i just was crying
didn't know these people but my heart
all i can say was my heart was like
shattered for him emotionally i was
wrecked and i had no idea why
who they were um and for for three days
i felt crazy because it had been 11
months
since i had tried any psychedelics um i
hadn't
tried to conjure this up i wasn't in a
visualization drill with a sports
psychologist
all of a sudden i was just lit up with
this vision i felt nuts for three days
couldn't tell anybody and and three days
later this guy named caleb
who had put on like survival trainings
uh around the world like survivalist
stuff
and uh he was friends with bear grylls i
like the man versus wild guy
and he was a humanitarian missionary
type guy and uh
i met caleb and i'm like man this might
be the guy i could tell he's kind of a
crazy guy
and so i tell caleb and he gets kind of
perked up and
he goes i know who they are and i said
what he goes
those are the the pygmy people i said
who and he goes there in the congo
and i was like where i hadn't been to
congo i hadn't been
i had never heard of the pygmy people at
this time
and he goes i'm so he goes it's so crazy
because i'm supposed to go see them in
three and a half weeks from now
just over three weeks from now he goes
but the team i was taking of men
there the three guys with them were all
husbands and all fathers
and they canceled their trip because the
rebels had taken over the airport that
they're flying into
over a million person city had been
overtaken by rebels
he's like the state department said no
american for any reason should travel to
the congo
um and so he goes look my wife was
telling me i should cancel my trip
unless i get some sort of sign that i'm
supposed to go he goes look man if you
go i'll go
and i was like what no well first i told
him no because it was crazy
it was too out there like it's dangerous
i don't know who these people are where
they are
um and so anyways three uh and a half
weeks later i tell caleb
and i told a guy named colin and three
and a half weeks later we're taking
numerous planes there
we land on a runway that literally they
cleared with machetes that was how they
mowed the lawn there
monkeys are jumping off the runway we
land we get on
a truck we drive like six hours we get
out we get on a motorcycle for a couple
hours we ride across a canoe
then also when we're hiking and we're
hiking in and all of a sudden we hear
drumming and then we hear singing and we
come into a clearing and the first guy
we meet
has tuberculosis and his ribs are
showing and he's coughing and he's
coughing
um and it all the way down to the fact
that caleb and colin were grabbing me
saying this is your vision
yeah bro this is your vision yeah and i
felt like this is nuts
did i have some sort of mental break or
mental labs like what's going on with me
um but even the chief pulled us to the
side and said hey everyone else calls us
the forest people we call ourselves the
forgotten
and when he said forgotten that was what
i had written to the
top of that piece of paper was forgotten
on the vision
um and so i knew known
then that like for some reason for some
purpose
like i felt like i was brought there but
i doubted it for quite a while
um because coming back the first time
kind of the visual i had
was i could try to help these people
that have such significant suffering
i could spend my whole life trying and
the visual i got was that it was like
emptying the ocean
with an eye dropper and like how long is
that going to take
and if i spent my whole life doing it
would it really make an impact
but man it's it's been wild like mike
have had a little boy named andy beau
pass away um i was cupping the back of
his head and holding his little hand and
he passed away just because of water
dirty water
dirty water so and his his mom was
sitting there with me
no it was just a water borne disease
i've had malaria now three times
um malaria oh bro it's brutal first time
i had it i vomited
red and green so as blood and bile after
like four or five days
um i lost 33 pounds in five days
um 60 60 to 70 or 65 to 70
of my bloodstream were parasites and so
my kidneys were failing my liver was
failing my veins were collapsing they
couldn't get ivs in me
and then uh i had black water fever
which is a side effect of malaria
25 to 50 percent of the people that get
black water fever they die
um so i was one of the few lucky ones
and uh
but whenever i finally was able to
urinate um
it was pitch black that's why black
water fever it was like motor oil or
something
but i couldn't urinate for five full
days and then whenever i did it was that
color
so it was brutal the joint pain unlike
anything you can imagine your neck your
shoulders
your elbows your wrists joints like just
radiating pain
and you feel like if we're in this room
right now it would feel like we were on
a ship
that was like 8 10 12 foot waves
on a boat like you're just rocking and
your your
fever goes way up uh for a short time
maybe 30 minutes or an hour and then it
plummets
and goes to where you're freezing so
actually when your
fever is up that's when you're cold and
then whenever your fever plummets like
96 that's whenever you're hot you're
just
overheating and so malaria was brutal
the three times i had it first time
almost killed me the second third time
weren't as bad
um but yeah i've had amoebas intestinal
parasites um and
a bunch of different stuff but hey this
is stuff they deal with on a daily basis
wow like i've had it but but they
are losing loved ones to it and so since
then fight for the forgotten we've been
able to get back their land rights
um over 3 000 acres of land for the
pygmy people
amazing and we're helping them drill
wells so we've drilled 61 water wells
for them
and then started up four working farms
so three are fully sustainable that are
supplying uh
different things like corn beans rice
bananas
to the local markets and then whenever
they're able to sell that
first they're able to eat it for
themselves then they're able to sell it
for others to eat
and then from that they make money to
where they can buy school
pay school fees or buy school uniforms
so their kids can go to school for the
first time
um but yeah i got to live in the twig
and leaf huts with them
for over a year so i've been doing this
since 2011
and um one time i went for a full year
and the other times you go for maybe a
month or two months or
or three weeks um and what we really try
to do is just to empower the locals
because they're the ones that want to be
the change they want to see in the world
or in their community or in their
country
and the thing is that i've learned real
quick is there's a great book called
when helping
hurts you can try to help but in the
long run you can hurt
if you don't do it in appropriate
sustainable ways
and so for instance in just water wells
if you look at that
there's over 230 000 broken wells in
africa right now
over 230 000 broken wells that are
minimum 5 000
each and so it's billions of wasted
charitable dollars
and the reason it's wasted is because
the locals weren't educated
with the knowledge how to do it for
themselves they weren't equipped with
the tools
to be able to do it for themselves and
they weren't empowered with
with like a self-sustaining business in
country
they have to depend on the outsiders to
do it for them
and so if a well breaks down after 11
months which they normally do
you have to really um have the locals
like like changing oil
after 3000 miles you have to be able to
to maintenance the well it might just be
a small nuts and bolts kind of
quick fix but if they don't know how to
fix it right it's never going to be
fixed
so whoa
what do you think about that vision
either one of you because i know that
sounds crazy
no i mean i think we both totally
believe in that stuff
yeah that makes a lot of sense man
um i mean we're not driving this thing
you know we're not in charge not at all
we're just passengers why are you doing
this
yeah you know we don't even know why we
do the things that we do
you know nobody knows but it's just the
reason it's a call to arms in a way
for me a call to arms like you said for
me on the tough days
whenever i felt like not necessarily
quitting but the really tough days that
make you question
why you're doing what you're doing um it
might be easier for me to do some other
things
and uh on those days you might want to
question i can go back to that
thing that's outside of me that isn't
just i want to do this
which is a great motivator i want to do
this but it's
i had this vision and there's a reason
and a purpose
for it and so after going there and
living and after bearing andy beau
they gave me the name efeosa
so efeosa means the man who loves us and
i love that one the most i treasure that
one but
[Laughter]
there you go it's pretty close uh that
means the big pygmy so
uh you're a big pig there we go how big
are those guys their average heights
four foot seven
for the men fourth and seven and here's
what's so crazy is people say
the army brutalized them yes uh now the
the
the congolese army or the ugandan army
uh ugandan yeah they they um so the
pygmy people live in nine african
nations
from uganda rwanda burundi congo
the other congo there's actually two
famous still yeah they do
in a lot of areas can you imagine that
black people are slaving black people
wow can you imagine yeah think of that
yeah
there's over 200 so we don't we don't
necessarily name the tribe normally
whenever we do our work we fight for the
forgotten
because in congo there's over 200 tribes
and only a few of them
might be doing this um but uh we say the
makpala which mean non-pygmy people
and then people say how do they have
this injustice that
um that this is still happening even
chris cyborg who is here with you guys
she came on our last trip to uganda i
remember seeing some
maybe while 10 years i remember seeing
some documentaries about
the harassment they were getting the
government's going and and they're
humiliating them and doing really bad
stuff
we're kicking them out of the forest in
a lot of areas where they're the
protectors of the forest
so to protect the forest why kick out
the protectors but why
do you how did the ugandans i know they
have a border but how do you again and
get the right across the border in her
after
well so there's pygmies that live in
uganda yeah and then
in um in congo and in central african
republic gabon cameroon
uganda and the congo never have a civil
war with each other they
do not like each other yeah yeah they've
been congo's been exploited they are the
richest country on planet earth for
natural resources for gold diamonds coal
tan rubber
yep absolutely
that's what heart of darkness is all
about yeah yeah and king leopold's ghost
is another great book and there's a
picture that you're talking about that's
so brutal because
um they think there was 20 million
congolese that lived in congo
when king leah pulled over he did a
number one oh man can i imagine
18 million kills that's why he did it
i'm on him like in the 1870s and 80s and
90s he died in like 1902
around that time neopol died and um
yeah he did a number on those people
yeah and listen he just went in there
and did it without anybody
and they had to stop them eventually
yeah he just got too brutal well people
in europe thought that king leopold was
like a hero
right bringing the light rubber to the
darkness and then they found out what he
was doing
and he said whoa yeah killed eight or
actually
um yeah eight to ten million people they
think like half the country
there and then the rest of the fifty
percent that lived um
half of them were missing one or more
limb because if they weren't working
hard enough
they would cut off their hands no no
they would cut off their babies their
wives
if you don't work you don't bring me
this amount of rubber today i'ma cut off
your daughter's hand
i'm a castrate your son i'ma do that
absolutely brutal where where the
picture you're talking about i think
there's a bunch of them out there but
there's a
father reaching out for his daughter
yeah yep he's reaching out for his
daughter
yep and his daughter's hands had just
been cut off and he's reaching out to
her with his hands
already removed and so no one has hands
and he's reaching out to his daughters
who just lost her two hands
like some of the most evil stuff you
could ever imagine like uh
i don't mean to say this bad about the
brand jameson but uh
but they even had um one of the sons
go out to the congo and he paid one of
the tribes
jameson whiskey one of the sons of the
jamison family
his last name was jameson he sent out a
tribe to go cannibalize
the pygmies so that he could do it for
artwork so he sat by
while they were cannibalizing a pygmy
and he
like painted the atrocities happening to
this person so he like
paid for it and it was his viewing
pleasure and then he painted it
out so one of the most evil things
[ __ ] james no but listen this is um
check it out i know we say [ __ ] but
this is what um
the elite people do especially in the
1900s the gilded ages
they experiment another human beings
were inferior to them
well on that in 1902 to 1906 people ask
how do they still suffer these kind of
um atrocities or no yeah still slavery
yeah now black people
are slave masters well so in in in
the bronx zoo 1902 to 1906 yes i
actually think 1902 humans
and they put them in the st louis world
fair from 1902 9204 in 1904 to 1906.
yeah he was in the bronx zoo and they
fed him bananas in the monkey house
so he literally lived with the monkeys
right there yeah um
so just brutal but what we're trying to
do even chris uh cyborg that was on the
show she helped us drill our first two
water wells in uganda
for the pygmy people there the batwa
pygmies had this been
what is the history of the pygmy people
so they first picked me what year were
they
in well anthropologists think they go
back uh tens of thousands of years
they're the first people group of even
africa they're at least
the first people group of congo so
they're the original
citizens the first citizens and so
similarly
to how with native americans here
there's been
land given to them for reservations it
was taken from them right it was all
taken from them
and then they've been given land back
that they can use and cultivate
and that they own um and it's the
strongest thing in courts like this
is cherokee land or this is well now we
have
3 000 acres of mabuti pygmy land in
congo
and we have five acres started in uganda
but we're looking at
right now because of chris cyborg and
then also dustin poirier
dustin poirier's helped done a big
fundraiser in his last fight
in abu dhabi against khabib nurmagomedov
and
they auctioned off the gear for fight
for the forgotten uh in the good fight
foundation
dustin poirier's organization and they
raised more than they thought we set a
goal at 25 000.
um we raised we blew past 50
then uh khabib donated his shirt for a
hundred thousand
dana white matched it for another
hundred thousand so i think it raised
like two hundred and eighty thousand
dollars
so now oh man now we're gonna be able to
drill seven water wells
and we're gonna be able to get back up
to well 30 acres of land is what we're
shooting for
but we're even aiming at maybe 100 acres
of land there
to try to get back but we have enough
funding for 30 acres of land
so that way they can start up their own
farm because this is what was brutal
they were kicked out of the simaliki
national forest in uganda by the ugandan
wildlife authority
and they have reasons to do that to
protect the forest that was being cut
down to protect the animals that were
being poached
but the pygmies aren't poachers they
only take what they need
um and then from there they were put on
one acre of land
behind through over 300 people given
here's your one acre plot of land
behind these slums and then they're
throwing out the
the sewage and the sewage comes through
their
village and they have eight shelters for
over 300 people
and so chris and i were walking around
and we uh
we were walking over these mounds and
chris cyborg stopped and said what are
these
mounds and she pointed down and uh dead
people
yeah they live on top of their grave
their graveyard
and so they've only been given one acre
of land they've dwindled down from over
300 people
to only 151 people in that area
and the chief was literally or king zito
is his name nzito
zito he was saying hey if we don't get
land soon
and have clean water and be able to farm
for ourselves ourselves
we've always hunted and gathered we
can't do that anymore we've got to be
able to farm for ourselves if we can't
do that soon
our people group isn't going to exist
anymore here that's crazy to think
my race of people is no longer going to
exist yeah isn't that wild
he literally drew in the dirt his his
dream and his
big audacious dream was land water food
and we're like man well we've done that
in the past we can do that here
all we need to do is have um rally
rally support and so what would some
bombs do to be
what would some people do in other
countries to be just a homeless bum in
america
they would give their life to be
homeless and obama in america
can you imagine yeah i i
i've said this before like women are
walking
miles and miles a day and children can't
go to school
because they're walking with 40
liters um or 20 liters which is five
gallons but a lot of times they carry
two at a time two of those buckets
20 liters is five gallons five gallons
is 44 pounds
when when full so they're walking day in
and day out two three times a day
with 44 pounds or 88 pounds of water
people come and rob them their water and
abuse them and stuff
it happens but normally um
normally not because oh where we go and
where we drill we always drill wells for
both sides
both tribes or everyone in the area so
it's communal
so this way it's not property of one
person
they're making yeah
well a lot of times whenever they're
able to hunt and gather in in congo
fat burgers or anything like that oh no
not that but i'm telling you some wild
bush meat uh
whether it's wild hog or antelope or
monkey i've had monkey before
um but fresh bananas and fresh sweet
potatoes from the ground and
uh that that's pretty good um goat goat
i think is a sweet meat
it's really incredible i used to go when
i was leaving me down all i ate all
jamaican people love coke yeah
absolutely all my friends that jamaican
oh
we all eat that goat [ __ ] yeah it's
sweet
it's a sweet meat i like it a lot
whenever it's grilled
um so yeah so that's that's kind of our
our overarching
vision as a non-profit is to defeat hate
with love
and our mission is to knock out bullying
worldwide and we do that in two areas
or two initiatives which are for the
pygmy people who anthropologists say are
the most oppressed people group on
planet earth
another way you could say that is the
most bullied and then here stateside
we have a bully prevention and character
development
uh initiative so it's community
development for the pygmy people
and it's character development here
stateside in martial arts academies
we want to be in boxing gyms we want to
be potentially in public
private online schools with a curriculum
for kids that basically says
well the name of it is heroes and
waiting and what that means the premise
is
a hero isn't someone with supernatural
powers superhuman strength
it's someone who simply sees a need and
takes action
they don't sit back and wait when
whenever bullying's happening
here's a great statistic our kids need
to know where anybody needs to know
is 87 of the time you stand up and say
something
one thing as easy as evan if you're
bullying mike i just say hey
that's not kind saying something as
simple as that hey that's not kind
eighty-seven percent of the time it
shuts it down within five to ten seconds
and so recognizing when you're being a
bystander
and knowing that if you are a bystander
like with raiden what happened
he was beat up in the the bathroom
standing by the urinal
and he's a kid with special needs he's
12 years old
he's got autism why did he beat him up
they shouldn't have this has been
happening for
for years since since he was a tribes
people
no no this is actually here his name is
raiden and it happened in oklahoma
and so kind of shifting to that our
stateside initiative
um raiden was in the bathroom at the
urinal
um 10 or 12 people are in the bathroom
four or five people are filming it and
he just gets pummeled right by the
urinal by this other kid that's a big
kid
the next day yeah let's pull that up
smash i don't want to see this
kid get beat up man well
there's there's a there's a good story
that comes from it so i might be able to
show you
the good stuff but yeah so
it's uh it's something that's on our
heart is how do we empower kids to
recognize when you're being a bystander
because the tough thing is is that
if they're not educated or equipped with
the right tools to say something
they won't where they'll think that
they'll wrongly think they're being
they're just uh innocent they're an
innocent bystander
whenever really if you're standing by
and watching or even if you're ignoring
it
you're not an innocent bystander you're
a silent supporter
you didn't choose it it chose you but
now you're presented with a choice
am i gonna do something or am i going to
do nothing
and if i choose to do nothing that is
doing something that's being a silent
supporter
and so you have to say something whether
your kid you'll report it you know to
the proper
school authority but man you can also
speak up and use your voice and that's
the most powerful thing against bullying
saying hey that's not kind hey stop that
or hey instead of a person being
excluded being an includer where you
invite them over in your group or sit at
your table or you go sit with them
when they're all alone and so when
that's being a hero in waiting
you know or heroin action is not sitting
by and doing nothing
are you ready here's this kid raiding
oh
this is this is thursday night and then
this is uh
raiden 12 born with autism or
born deaf in his right ear has a hearing
aid is diabetic
been bullied since he was nine this is
on the yard
the very next day so thursday was in the
bathroom this is friday
and three kids on him at once
and yeah they found him with with a
sharpie mark on his arm
because of the bullying um he's wrote on
his arm like i want to kill myself
and um so we live in the same hometown
in oklahoma city and uh they've um
they asked us to get involved and to see
them but what's been kind of cool is
have you ever heard of rafael lovato jr
no so he is the current bellator
champion
he's right there on the left oh man and
so this was a few nights later
uh raiden got to hold raphael's current
bellator championship he's the
middleweight champion beat gegard
musassi
that's one of my training partners and
coaches he's the best american or at
least the most accomplished american
to do jiu jitsu he's got numerous world
medals i think six of them are gold
medals
in jiu jitsu and then uh and then he's
the current mma
world champion so that's his little
brother brock
on the right raden's 12 his little
brother's nine
raiden's a big kid i mean that's uh i'm
i'm six two six three
250. raphael's the 185 world champion
and uh raiden is 12 years old he's a big
kid
but he's a sweetheart if you go back
or next actually if you keep going i'll
be able to show you
that's that's actually the next night so
tuesday
his school was canceled this is
wednesday night tuesday
his school was canceled because of death
threats at the school because all this
went so crazy
people were cyber bullying raiden and
his family or not just him but
the bullies people started posting the
address of the 12 and 13 year olds
online saying go get them um and so uh
his dad asked rayden if he was going to
go to church the next night
and rayden goes no dad what are the kids
from school going to say
school is canceled because of me i've
been bullied and beat up i can't go back
to even church
and i go what if i go with you bud and
uh he looks as dad can i
and his dad goes yeah and he looks at me
and says can i wear a shirt like you i'm
like yeah buddy so
uh we went to his church and like 300
kids heard he was coming out they all
came to support him
um i got to speak for like 5-10 minutes
share my bullying story share about how
we can rally around raiden
and he got a standing ovation from 300
kids at his school
um and afterwards we're leaving and some
of the girls asked him hey rayden
how are you he goes i'm okay and they go
are you coming back next week and he's
like
yeah i'll come back and after that he
goes dad do you see that
and he goes yeah um and we sit in the
car and i go raid him what was your
favorite part bud
and he goes well everyone cheering for
me that made me want to cry
but the girls definitely the girls that
was my favorite part
um and so we're just trying to rally
support around him where you know
he was sitting there depressed his
grandpa named butch that's his dad danny
but butch was old bull rider um and he
says it's
made his heart want to fall out of his
chest that at nine years old was the
first time his grandson
talked about wanting to kill himself
because he's been bullied for
for most his life um so uh
we're just trying to put love and
compassion
in action and have a bunch of people
rally support around them i mean
people have posted about raiden from the
pittsburgh steelers all posting a video
for him
the la chargers uh rafael lovato jr
baker mayfield uh mick foley is their
favorite wwe wrestler
um he has a son that's autistic he made
a video for raiden sent it out
um and a lot of really cool stuff is
happening it's amazing man
unless you've been living under a rock
you've known that the nfl
is back and the nba players are in full
swing which can only mean one thing
it's winning season at my bookie to
start one and go to my bookie just use
the promo code tyson
claim your 100 deposit match all the way
up to a thousand
bucks that means if you put 100 bucks in
you'll get another 100 bucks
it's easy easy way to jumpstart your
bankroll
nfl nba mlb they all got
all never too late to start your own
winning season
exclusively at my bookie
mike have you heard of uh hyperbaric
oxygen therapy i was in the hyperbaric
chamber before
really yeah yeah this is with raiden
uh i was actually with him at the
doctor's right in here
why is he in there because he was
actually diagnosed with a concussion
yeah it came out
i was brainstormed so they they said
that uh hyperbarics were one of the best
things for give him a concussion
uh from one of those fights oh [ __ ] yeah
so um
i was helping get him getting them down
uh he had never done it before and i'm
one of those guys that thinks everything
happens for a reason
and so i just started hyperbarics you're
one of those guys yeah
no accident no accident so i had just
started going two or three times
and then uh the doctor said hyperbarics
would be great for him
i was like i have an appointment today
and uh if we can get him a prescription
i'll take him with me
and so i was able to help him he hasn't
been in a plane before
so we brought him down and been just
trying to rally
support around him there he is with
someone's sunglasses now
eskimo joes you know about that in
oklahoma
yeah he's a big oklahoma fan he just
wants to be loved
that's it yeah i love people my god
so that's our mission man is to defeat
hate with love and how can we do that in
the most practical
tangible way whether that's um for the
most bullied people group or whether
that's here for
kids that are being bullied stateside
because what's nuts about just in the
u.s
the number two cause of death three ages
ten to fourteen bullying yep suicide
uh teen addiction teen depression
teen isolation um
teen like self like uh what's that
mutilation yeah
it's it's education and all that stuff
it's through
the roof higher than ever before yeah
exactly i wanted to say that i will say
like um
you know um that's why we have so many
help
groups and we got the earl nightingale
nightingales and all these guys the
the justin um the guy barry perry
and all these guys and the guru
and those guys because people need
people need outlet people need help
yeah people need to find something
bigger than outside themselves and
that's inside themselves
to help them live another day yeah
because we're looking for all of our
happiness and to solve all our problems
out here
and out of the world and all the
problems solving this
has to be done inside of the inside job
when it's out here this disturbs this in
here it's normally
over it's finished the objective is to
keep the outer world from
disturbing the inner world yeah
i like that a lot that it's an inside
job oh big time in there
there's so many i think especially with
social media
and cyber bullying right like whenever
we were being bullied growing up like
you could escape it when school was over
let's go home but now it increases and i
think comparison
what's that quote um it's like teddy
roosevelt or
something like that says comparison is
the thief of joy
yeah and like all these kids on social
media they're just comparing up
right to everyone else's highlight reel
even if it's a fabricated
highlight reel um and so do you think
that's the
why there's so much bullying now i think
that's one of the main reasons
social media yeah or at least that's one
of the most active ways to do it because
you can be anonymous
or it even if it's not anonymous and
you're truly doing it with your identity
you are almost numb to the real effects
because it's not a person to person
face to face-to-face interaction so you
can
hide behind your your there's a buffer
there behind your
your smartphone yeah or whatever and so
180 000 kids 180
000 in the us alone skip school every
day because of bullying i skipped school
yeah i skipped school big time 3 million
school days lost a month
12 million american students will be
bullied this year alone
this is what i do i used to get bullied
for school i would go to school for
breakfast
when breakfast is over i will leave the
school and wait outside the school
until lunchtime long time ago i would go
eat lunch boom
lunch time i will wait in school when
the school is over i'll go get my books
and i go back home
wow i'm never going to school because
they would [ __ ] kick my ass
and i had to get the food once i got the
food i got the food and i left
because they had it before their class
came and saw me in the the
the lunch run they wanted certain people
to see me in that lunchroom
because everybody just come and attack
me take my flip then they beat your ass
right in front of everybody no one does
anything they just beat your ass
just like that but they do it right in
front of the um the cafeteria teaches
the guards they'll be beating your ass
you know i always make sure i got the
food and i was out before that class
came down
wow yeah i would uh after that bullying
moment where i was
dressed up like the dr pepper uh
transformer
i literally ran away from that party my
parents had to find me
at dairy queen afterwards i had ripped
it all off thrown it in the
uh the dumpster i had like the duct tape
residue still on my shirt and jeans and
stuff like that
i was sitting there crying just sobbing
i skipped school until i think
that was on the weekend i think it was
thursday or friday when my parents
finally sent me back
but there's a thing called the diffusion
of responsibility i think is what it's
called in psychology
where when there's a group people take
on less personal responsibility to do
something about it
because there's a group and someone else
could do something and
what we need to know is like have that
primed in our mind that even though
there's other people that could do
something i'm going to do something
whenever i see bullying taking place
is it human nature bullying
do you think this is absolutely animals
do it humans you do it
you know certain animals they bully
their brothers and sisters and stuff
and then as they get older they love
each other and fight to the death for
each other
someone has to somebody have to um
determine who's the boss
and that find a way and that development
of
who they are in life they might have to
develop i'm the boss or he's the boss
it's just no way it's just that's how
it's always from animals brothers and
sisters
some animals i think it's her um hyenas
they fight in the womb
they have they may have seven babies one
or two might come out cause they're
fighting
they're fighting in the womb they'll
kill each other before they get out
yeah well i think that's probably where
the big challenge comes from right like
battling that nature versus us being
civilized
human beings now yeah and needing to uh
to shift in a way that okay we know that
this now
through science and through studying it
we know that this has long lasting
detrimental effects but it's fear-based
yeah absolutely
it's all fear-based even in the womb
with the animals it's all fear-based am
i going to get out of here i'm going to
kill them but i got to get out of here
yeah it's all for your everything's
fear-based
if baby just hey it's cool enough this
is my brother i love him he loves me
and we're going to get out this way it's
okay it's okay
but they can't ration animals don't
ration
they don't have no rationalization they
can't do that stuff
well there's that and then there's also
a trickle down happening
isn't there from the parents from their
parents
yeah don't doubt about it what i had to
tell raiden um because he couldn't
really understand
um how he was treated so badly by a
group
of people like the thing that happened
in the bathroom
even though it was on school property
that one affected him less
than whenever there was these two guys
beating them up and this girl hit them
from behind
and then everyone filming it and i had
to tell them
you know buddy um we have this thing we
do we fist pound and then we say buddies
and we do like two pounds on our chest
just fist bump
buddies and uh i said well you know
buddy sometimes
um this is what i've learned through my
bullying moments
is that hurt people hurt people
[Music]
and there's some things that are going
on and i won't say who but
one of the people from that video if you
look into their background like someone
in their family very close to them one
of their parents were murdered
by their other parent and so they're in
a very tough
life circumstance of their own and they
should have probably been removed from
school the year before
but because of that tragic instance in
their life
they've kind of been given a little bit
of some free passes a bit maybe
and and then they're they're struggling
they're hurting
and so they act out by hurting others
and if you look into the statistics from
the cdc
um number three on the suicide list
for like bullying moments and the third
at risk is the bully
the second is actually the victim and
you're like well who would be number one
well actually number one at highest risk
of suicide is the person who does both
they're being bullied and then they're
not happy with themselves so they act
out by being a bully to others
so that person is the highest at risk of
suicide the person that
is being bullied and then they become a
bully because they're not happy
on either side and so they're at this
constant internal
struggle with who they are we don't talk
about this guy
you know do you remember this because
what about the guy that kills the bully
that guy too the guy that kills the
bully and sometimes um
i saw him one time on television um it
was this guy he was beating up the guy i
forgot his name
and he even took he even took sexual
advantage of some of the girls in the
group in them
and they just made a plan one day that
we're gonna get him and so
the guy had made a plan for us to go out
again and they called that guy to come
in
and they killed him
it was on uh it's on the 2020 before i
saw it
so it's not always that someone's
getting bullied sometimes people fight
back
and then they spend the rest of their
life in jail from being bullied from
defending you for they they went too
extreme
they then go to the cops they then go to
their parents they put in their own
hands
that was a smart idea and they killed
the guy well i think that's
one of the big struggles with school
shootings if you look at school
shootings you'll see
75 percent of time or more they were
relentlessly bullied
at school and this was their given
attention as well they haven't been
given attention they believed they
deserved because they've been good and
nice to those people and they haven't
received the same in return
yeah so justin from that
perspective how are you building the
character
of this next generation well that's what
we're really excited about we worked
with uh
century martial arts um and they're the
number one distributor of martial arts
goods
in the world so if you buy anything at
dick's or
um academy they've made most of it
and they supply most of the martial arts
academies around the country and
one thing that i think boxing wrestling
jiu jitsu does that maybe maybe football
football develops character for sure
without a doubt but i think the coaching
in martial arts like there's lessons
before
during and after practice about
character about discipline about respect
about
treating others like you'd want to be
treated even the black belt journey is
about
service to others and so um i love that
about martial arts and so we worked with
century martial arts and another
organization called maya the martial
arts industry association
and they've helped us develop this
curriculum that's
12 weeks of teaching and then every
class they have a matte chat
so a matte discussion and so there's a
teaching
and then there's also a challenge
there's a hero's challenge after every
heroes and waiting lesson
and so they'll be like this week and
it's all digital too so they can watch
it on their smartphone going into
practice
we coach the coaches how to coach it
then there's a video for the parents
there's a video for the students that
are learning
so the parents can be engaged with what
their child is learning
and the student can know what they're
learning that week and what their hero
challenge is
and so what i love about that is they
come in week one recognize when you're
being a bystander
and so recognize that come back and
report it another hero challenge will be
go out and complete a secret random act
of kindness
so the rule is you have to be completely
anonymous and you have to go do
something great that makes someone feel
awesome
and what was that journal it you know
what'd you do
how did you stay anonymous how'd that
make them feel how that make you feel
and then how are you going to build on
to that next week and so it's all
all digital but there's also a
curriculum that's all typed out
and so we're arming or right now 104
martial arts academies are using it
around the country
and now we're just trying to fundraise
that way we can get it up to school
standards
and get it into public private and
online schools
get it accredited and so that's we're
working with our board now
that's awesome um
i guess outside of that
how do we cultivate kindness
and goodness in young people
i think so that it's not just like okay
you're in a situation and a kid's being
bullied are you gonna be a bystander
this is what they do
they know how to do this you get
programs
kids and kids would join the program the
programs would keep teaching everybody
um the golden rule you know the program
but they but the government always i'm
pulling these programs out
the more programs i think are better for
the children it'll be less drugs
it'd be less killing it'll be more
programs more con
conglomerates more people being friends
more people meeting each other
and that's what is so many people
disenfranchise with each other they're
so far away from each other they can't
be together and they're looking they
want
their minds are reaching for each other
but also disenfranchised
and that's what the programs do well i
love this there's a you just
triggered a swahili proverb in my mind
my memory
the pygmies taught me this it says if
you want to go fast
go alone but if you want to go far
go together and so we need these
programs we need everyone to come
together and then what i've learned
there from living there for years
the community it's so important and
we're so used to isolating
or being individuals that we'll do
things on our own
and in the rain forest you don't have
privacy your your home is literally twig
and leaves
your wall are leaves and so you can hear
the discussions between people
all across the village there isn't any
private conversations and that can be a
bad thing but it's also a good thing
that you aren't able to isolate and
completely
cut yourself off from from the community
and so you need each other
but i also think it's really important
for each individual to learn their
personal
impact you can impress people from a
stage or
from maybe on a podcast but you impact
people
one-on-one in conversation or up close
and so what i mean by that is we could
teach these kids
uh whether it's in a program or whether
it's in a conversation with them
that no act of kindness no act of
kindness no matter how small
ever goes wasted right and so start
small
i've gotten to start this organization
fight for the forgotten now it's going
to be what i do for the rest of my life
but i started with that quote no act of
kindness no matter how small ever goes
wasted
and so one thing i like to ask people is
in the lives of others
if you knew you could if you knew you
could in the lives of others
what great difference would you make if
you only knew you could
so it's that whole that whole quote you
know
um what would you do if you knew you
wouldn't fail what would you do
if you knew you wouldn't fail and so
take all the fear
of failure away well now what difference
would you make
in the lives of others if you didn't
have fear that you wouldn't
be able to do it and so what impact do
you want to make how do you want to
influence people how do you want to
change their lives
and and so do that no act of kindness no
matter how small ever goes wasted start
small
start somewhere and uh just have your
head on a swivel
looking to make a difference wherever it
is you can i love that
i always tell my son um to all my kids
dads if you're just somewhere i don't
care where you're at
never think um why am i here you think
when you get there you observe the
situation you're in
say how can i make this a better place
wow
how can i make these people better at
what they do
and i know that sounds like i don't [ __ ]
if i care what they do
imagine imagine your brain working to
make this place better
yeah and make these people better than
they could ever be in their life
and no one can do it but you could that
thought came to your mind to make this
better
it's perfect but you can make this
better and that's your job to make this
better i'd love that mike
you know what's really cool is that's
even a principle now that i think
can even be applied to businesses
i was recently at both lowe's in
charlotte
um north carolina and home depot in
atlanta georgia and both of them talked
about something really similar which
kind of blew me away
but there's a new statistic out there
that says i think it's 84.
84 of consumers are now classified as
consumers who care
what that means is they're looking to
buy a product or a service
that's attached to a purpose that it's
cause-minded
community-driven that it's making the
world a better place
and so if businesses can even align with
that if us as people can align with that
like you'll just make the world a better
place yeah and so it's been really cool
to see
some of these businesses step up and say
like this is how we're going to give
like we've got
one guy that gives 10 uh of his company
back to us
that's awesome another person that gives
a certain dollar amount per
product sold and that that's been nuts
to see their sales increase from being
uh purpose driven or attached to a cause
i love that
that's our purpose here that's our
purpose i always wanted to know who's
the human purpose here
and it's to enrich the world yeah
someone's going to come arrive one day
and they're going to say
i can make us live for an extra hundred
years
he's going to enrich the world and i
don't know if that's enriching the world
but
that'll be a form of enriching the world
absolutely
whatever it is what are we doing right
now the form of enriching the world
yeah and the way now see now we have
this
you know how many millions and hundreds
of millions of people know that he does
this now
that's enriching the world he touched
millions of people knows his
idea what he's doing yeah even people in
the congo know now they didn't know
yeah you know enriching the world with
his love
and caring for you know humanity
you know it's powerful stuff man
i think that's so important to remember
you know
as no act of kindness no matter how
small goes
you know you say the universe allowed us
to be born
maybe we didn't want to be born and now
we're born
and now we gotta worry and freak out
about dying
you know yeah he put us here we didn't
have to be here and now we're freaking
out about dying
you know how do you do this why are you
having me freaking out
yeah what's that saying though uh the
most important day of your life
isn't the day that you were born but the
day you found out why
yeah or something like that the day you
discovered why yeah and i found out
during richard the world
yeah there's no no doubt there's no
doubt to enrich the world
i love that that's easy to say yeah easy
to live by no and this is what i found
out too
human beings animals yes but [ __ ]
human beings
won't set won't accept
won't accept um they won't accept the
answer unless it's complicated
if the answer's easy they won't believe
it they say it's [ __ ]
you know i mean even our reality is in
our mouth
you know i i know this will sound
probably pretty cheesy but i
i need easy simple things for me to
remember exactly
that's why our vision statements defeat
hate with love that's pretty easy defeat
hate with love knock out bullying
worldwide
um defend the weak love being loved
empower the voiceless like those kind of
things
but whenever i'd sign my book i got to
write a book called fight for the
forgotten
and uh whenever i'd sign it it was a
reminder to me but i hope it would kind
of be an awakening or a moment where if
someone actually
what does this mean that they would
think about it and discover it
that it's almost too simple to live by
yeah but it's i would sign it live to
love
love to live and it was because i
whenever i was going through that
being that depressed drunk drug addict
and hitchhiking from
drug house to drug house and fighting on
tv and getting my hand raised and
thinking is this it is this all like not
having that
sense of fulfillment uh after a victory
where that i thought would be there
no doubt about it listen um dr seuss
the cat in the hat he's frederick
nietzsche in simple form
you know physically you try to respect
frederick nietzsche you won't understand
one [ __ ] word when it comes out to
your mouth nobody here will understand
one word what did he say
you understand everything in the cat in
the hat that's frederick nietzsche right
there everything
the world right there my my wife's been
literally telling me i have to read the
cat
oh definitely i haven't read them
definitely oh that's the world
okay it's the other world cat in the hat
well that's it though if
if you think about just those two things
live to love love to live
we're all wanting to love this one life
that we live
and so we get caught in what's that
called like
materialism we get caught in all this
because we just
the new iphone will make me happy this
new car will make me happy this bigger
home will make me happy
um for a moment for a moment but the
thing is is that if we change things up
if we live to love
first i think we'll love to live
and it's about like you know let's go
all this has to go all the new phones
all the new clothes
the blunts everything the fancy
everything has to go
that's why at the end of the day we're
just with skeletons smiling at the end
of the day all of us skeletons with a
big smile on our face
into the day we just passing through
yeah
you know maybe have we gone on a ride
you know we're gonna exist somewhere
else
but not here in this physical world
that's when we go as soon as we die
that's when we're gonna begin to live
you know that's just when we're going to
start
so can you can you imagine dying and can
you just imagine dying and waking up and
being somewhere else
that's wild after after experiencing all
this can you imagine
we're not living them when i was
somewhere else not knowing where but
we're there
someone told me once that and this might
be a common quote but i forget i'm
trying to think who told me it but they
said we're not
human beings on a spiritual journey
we're spiritual beings on a human being
i was talking to my wife the other day
because i was watching my son he plays
baseball
and so we're sitting down in the rafters
and so with the ants there and it's
getting wintertime so they're ready to
hibernate now but
the whole all during spring and summer
they were um
they're preparing right and i'm telling
my wife that story and i'm when i'm
going on and i say baby you see this
they're doing all this under the midst
of us squashing them and stabbing they
accomplished more than we could ever do
in a lifetime
within a season and that's being
questioned stopped by us
right and i said now baby listen to this
you see how we're watching them
who's watching us
you don't think somebody's watching us
in perspective definitely
and i wanted to answer have somebody
they look at that's very small like we
look at them
i wanted their species to bug that's
very small the dance looked at them and
said
they're too small even to [ __ ] eat
you know and do they have somebody
smaller than them that they say they're
too small even
they're just amazing to look at like we
look at the bugs
we might just kill them for sport you
know
how many how many um how many layers of
that
the smaller the smallest the smallest
microscopic
how many layers did that go
well where does it start from us where
does it go
the clouds is the universe is the solar
system
where does it start when they're looking
at us and we're microscopic
i don't know you're blowing my mind
well but we can't think with we can't
think listen
we don't like ourselves well enough to
think we don't own the strongest beings
in the universe
we don't love ourselves enough to really
believe we're the only ones
yeah you just you just pulled another
swahili proverb
out of my memory um about not believing
in ourselves enough um there's a swahili
proverb and this
this means more to me because i've had
malaria now uh
three times and and a bigger beast of an
opponent
that i've ever fought um was a was a one
gram or less than
mosquito right that almost took me out
almost laid me out
permanently but it says if you think
you're too small to make a difference
try to sleep in a closed room
with a mosquito and so if there was one
mosquito in this room with us right oh
he'll make a difference
get my wife will forget this
[ __ ] out of here
i said baby this is just a bug what do
you do get him out of here
a bug he doesn't eat too much he doesn't
eat much at all
he's going to die he odin on you eating
off you
you're not going to die chill and so if
that one bug can make that big of a
difference
in our lives how much more of a
difference can we make in the lives of
others
exactly exactly many people don't think
that they have any power
you know hey that's the power right
there
that should let them know they have
power because that's the power to show
them that nothing
because they're being nothing so tell
that power to tell you something
and you'll be something yeah
absolutely remember what you told me
whatever you think
right or wrong you're good or bad you're
right
yeah because you thought that that's
right
and that that feeling of powerlessness
i think when kids are bullied growing up
those effects those feelings those
beliefs
of being powerless can last a lifetime
yeah if you let it yeah if someone
doesn't come along
and show you yeah or you have some some
moment of self-discovery
that lets you know that that you do have
uh power
um you know believe there's no i bullies
see people understand the real
damage that bully do bully um bullies
bullies make monsters yeah that's the
biggest damage they do
those little scared people turn into
monsters
the bully couldn't even fathom the fear
that that guy could imagine
you know that's the
do real remember one significant
bullying moment in your life
hey but i'm not cool enough to see the
guys that bullied me right now to this
day
i might attack him right now i'm 53
years old i might attack him right now
yeah they didn't number
i uh i saw some of the bullies from that
that party
so i'm at a sushi restaurant after i got
off the ultimate fighter tv show
i was visiting my hometown in fort worth
texas and um
is that a sushi place and it was crazy
it was almost that
that group of kids that set it all up
that pre-planned it
that methodically created an invitation
that said costume party on it knowing
that it wasn't a costume party it was
just to fool me
and so there's a table of eight eight or
ten of them
and the the main kind of ring leader of
that group
that had set up numerous bullying
moments for me um
the years before he saw me said oh why
don't you come over have a drink with us
i was like no that's okay and he pointed
over at the
the table i was like no that's okay and
and i went to the restroom
and uh actually sorry before i went to
the restroom he pulled me over to the
table
it was all of them sitting down and they
kind of went around the table and it was
all something
similar to this effect but the guy that
was the the ringleader
looked at me brought me over there to
the table i stopped by just for a second
he said hey here's so and so so and so
so and so you remember them
i'm like yeah i remember them and he
goes hey man
you know we were just kids back then uh
if we knew you were going to be a
fighter
and you could have beat us all up we
would have never done that to you
and uh i think he was trying to say
sorry
but what i got from that was if if he
would have known
that i could have whooped them he
wouldn't have done those terrible things
to me
that's how i received it was oh if you
knew there was a consequence you
wouldn't have done that
and so i remember from there i went to
the bathroom
said hold on give me a minute i went to
the bathroom and just like when i ran
away from that party
after that moment i like slipped out i
didn't slip out the back but i found a
way
around in the restaurant to where they
didn't see me leaving
um and so i couldn't even face them then
i'm not that i can't handle that yeah
well i'm too insecure i would be violent
you know he's too insecure he's too
insecure
too insecure
one of the one of the reasons i'm in
town i'm going on joe rogan's podcast
i'm i'm on with you guys i'm so
incredibly grateful
um it looks like raiden there's going to
be some really cool stuff lining up for
him maybe with the chargers maybe with
the talk to the tv show there's a
cbs show called seal team that might
give him a studio tour
take him on walk hike with him yeah go
to the beach
part of this by himself his first time
on a airplane we'll be coming out here
and
take him to the beach for the first time
which is going to be great
but actually mike there's this
incredible doctor in costa mesa
his name is dr daniel amen and
he did muhammad ali's brain looked at it
on scans
he's done tons of nfl players like over
300 i think
and he can detect mild traumatic brain
injury all this different stuff
and he said for a fighter i have a
really good brain he had to do i do
three full days with him his chief
medical director uh his functional
medicine doctor
but they did cheek swabs hair swat hair
samples uh blood urine stool samples
they did the works on me trying to
figure out what parasite i have in me
because i've had cerebral malaria which
is the parasite that normally is in the
liver but it's gone into my head
i've had intestinal bacterias amoebas
amoebas up here too
um so they're doing the works on me
checking me out jesus
um but they literally can scan your
brain and see where the blood flow is
where it's where there's too much
activity where there's not enough
activity and where it's functioning
properly
but then they can detect on these scans
it's called a spect scan
and they can show you this 3d image of
your brain and it's almost like an mri
but way different it shows the function
of your brain not just the biology of
your brain
and it can actually show you your
emotional brain
and where it's firing and so they can
see eight different types of brains that
are add
i have severe add they can detect mild
traumatic brain injury
like then tbi regular they can detect
all this different stuff
but for me they're able to detect ptsd
and so the way your brain's supposed to
be lit up is supposed to be just a
little bit of red
one spot that might have white well my
brain was all over the place
lit up everywhere and there's a certain
diamond and it
they show you what part of the brain
connects to and everything else on the
underside and on the frontal
all these different parts of the brain
but they showed me that
i had a diamond of fire and they say if
you have this ring of fire
that means a hundred percent you have
ptsd you're supposed to have just one
little red
speck there you've got it lit up and you
have it in
a circle they're in a diamond like i
mean you have
as much ptsd as as military veterans
that come in here and
and are really struggling with it and
i've had some terrible stuff happen
growing up as a kid but then even over
in the congo in uganda from rebel group
interactions and being
held at gunpoint or rebels attacking a
village next to us or taking women to
the hospital after they've been
tied to a tree and raped by numerous men
and
just like some really really tough stuff
seeing and digging graves for people
and different things like that um
not really why i brought up dr ehman but
i know that
he's an incredible doctor and he's
helping me get a life balance of like a
morning routine
supplements that help my brain there can
be medications too but
that's his last line of defense is he
wants to help create healthy brains
because he says
if we can help you have a healthy
healthy brain you'll have a healthy life
and so he's helped a ton of different
nfl muhammad ali a lot of different
people
and now he's helping me and my wife so
i'm very grateful for him
amazing i wonder what i got i know i
must have submission
you should go see him he's right here in
costa mesa he really is a phenomenal
doctor he's uh he's
he's he's a 10 10 time new york times
bestseller
really two two ted talks with millions
of views
he talks to google to success magazine
forbes
um he's not just some doctor he's like
the doctor how do you spell his
brain scans amen like you're praying
amen amen so it's dr
daniel ayman and he works with nfl
players fighters
all sorts of people and he's done more
brain scans than any human on earth like
over 200 000 different brains
and that's where he's getting all this
state of the art technology and able to
write as books
like how how to heal your brain with the
hyperbarics they're finding that
yeah you can literally do brain trauma
reversal
through hyperbarics yeah this little
girl named eden carlson
she drowned she was gone for two hours
a normal little girl again wow yeah
it's amazing man well justin i mean
you you're just you're an angel dude i
mean you're doing some incredible work
and i'm i've been on the verge of tears
basically this whole
conversation and i really appreciate
everything you're doing
i think it's amazing
is there anything before we wrap up
anything you want to
mention make sure people know about
where they can follow you
all of that yeah if you if you feel led
to do anything with raiden
go check out the hashtag stand with
raiden
so it's called stand with raiden and i
bet he would love
i text him videos back and forth his
parents videos
every day him and i and i've taken to
the hyperbarics 20 times myself
i've had family dinners at his house his
his grandma can cook some meatloaf
absolutely she can cook some meatloaf um
and uh the barrack chambers are some
really
illustrative it's all it's been done
like 30 years been doing it for over 30
but it's just
it's really something special i had one
when i played yeah
he's he's um he's getting better sleep
than he's ever gotten
he's not up and down in the night
anymore he's able to focus more at
school
and he feels more positive he's having
less and less of those suicidal thoughts
um so it's hashtag stand with raiden and
then uh if people want to support
fight for the forgotten probably the
easiest and newest way to do that
is becoming part of our fight club and
so kind of like fight club the movie the
first rule is you don't speak about
fight club or second rule is you don't
speak about fight club
our first rules that you do speak about
fight club let people know that you're
part of our monthly giving club
and you can give up a latte every month
or starbucks drink and
send us five dollars a month and that
helps us know our our budget for the
year
um and uh the more monthly donors we get
we we get to plan out how many wells we
get to drill how many kids here
stateside we get to help
how much land we can buy throughout the
year and so that's by becoming part of
our fight club you can get t-shirts
there
all that it's just fight for the
forgotten.org and then you just click on
the fight club
awesome i think that's pretty cool
you're a hell of a man yeah thank you my
man brother
yeah thank you justin i'm so grateful
for you guys this is awesome
uh this is kind of a dream come true for
me meeting you guys
thank you it's amazing dream come true
to have you in here
yeah [ __ ] eh we like having guys like
you that make a difference in the world
yeah you know a nice show yeah thank you
it's so important right now
you know i think there's a big there's a
lot of
disillusionment with being
a human right now you know and we're in
a crisis
of needing connection well you know a
lot of people don't understand um
why they don't make themselves why am i
not happy
yeah why don't make me happy no why and
i used to say that too
and didn't know what i did i helped
somebody and then i got addicted to
helping people right
people thinking i was special i was nice
and they're giving me a good reputation
because i was helping them
because mike is a good man if you ever
had some money mike if you have you
needed mike
and then that that um i got addicted to
that yeah everybody's saying i'm a good
[ __ ] he's a hell of a
[ __ ] he's beautiful
and that's addicting helping people for
stuff like that that's addicting too
yeah definitely absolutely
you feel that rush you never know you
think connections you just don't know
what's wrong [ __ ] then you [ __ ]
clean somebody's yard out and you
[ __ ] get a rush
i'm gonna do another one yeah yeah yeah
well i think it goes back to that saying
hurt people hurt people
but loved people love people or even
maybe helped
people in turn help people so once you
are helped you can help someone else
exactly yeah and it is about that
connection community yeah relationship
yeah because we can have all the stuff
in the world but if we don't have people
yeah it doesn't have to be a ton of
people but it has to be meaningful
people in our lives absolutely you won't
have much meaning without those
meaningful relationships it's awesome
it's great stuff man thanks justin
thank you very much mike great show
amazing great spiritual show this is
this is what we took one of the things
that i call
mind stuff you know it's good stuff yeah
it's awesome thank you well everybody
thank you so much for tuning in be sure
to head to fightfortheforgotten.org
you can also stand with raiden
through following justin the big pygmy
on social media
how boxing love rating hot boxing stands
with raiden without a doubt
i love that um head to our website
hotboxingpodcast.com
be sure to subscribe to our youtube
channel until next time
i'm evan britton i'm mike tyson and
we're out of here brother bye
peace is beautiful man hey thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you